I'm great happy belated birthday by the
way thank you and you were just bringing
the vava boom soon he's trying Hey you
bringing it and this hair is a red
strawberry blonde what would you call it
yeah it's like orangey um yeah amgk
oh I love it
hey what'd you make of that cover empty
Kevin hi
he says that cover is hot it's Megan
yeah what was your first reaction when
as I called you to say we want you to be
one of our couple gals
um I think I had sort of manifested it a
little bit earlier a few weeks earlier I
had been like you know I really think I
should do the cover of Sports
Illustrated I've never done it I've been
in Hollywood for a long time and then a
few weeks later they called and they
were like do you want to do the covers
Illustrated so basically you spoke into
existence did you think of that growing
up like you wanted to be on this cover I
didn't I think it was probably too too
high of an aim when I was little to
think of that because you're just a
little kid from wherever you're from I'm
from Tennessee but I think like just
realizing like wow I've been doing this
a long time what would be really what's
a what's a bucket list goal like as
someone who's been in this industry for
so long and being on Sports Illustrated
was definitely one of them Megan I wish
you saw yourself how we see you it was
very interesting to learn about unsi
that you have body dysmorphia which is
basically you don't see yourself as
other people do in what ways are you
working on your journey of self-love
these days
um I do a lot of I I've sought
throughout my life a lot of different
forms of therapy and right now I do a
lot of I prefer like metaphysical
approaches and holistic approaches to
Healing so um I I have a lot of people I
I speak with and I'm always reading
books and trying to learn more about
myself and trying to open up and I think
for me it's a lot about healing
childhood trauma because that's where
the root of that comes from for me so
that's what I'm working on right now I
always appreciate okay
foreign